[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome to another episode of
whats up Prof
Mar well that was a synch synchronized
yes that was very synchronized are you
doing well I'm trying and you well yeah
I the Lord sustains us but there's very
interesting things happening but we have
to focus on how to get ready yes so the
topic today is standing in the time of
trial and it was initiated by a comment
or a question yeah on our last WhatsApp
Prof so I'll put the question on the
screen or this comment and then we can
discuss it
but before we do that we should pray and
then I just want to do some housekeeping
all right let's pray and do
housekeeping our heavenly father thank
you very much for bringing us together
again thank you for having that we can
be able to do these discussions would
you Enlighten our minds and bless the
discussion in Jesus name amen
amen so what's the housekeeping Martin
okay it's just a few pointers that I
want to bring out for people because um
they are we've had some trouble on our
YouTube channel with videos being taken
down um so I want to remind the viewers
that we have alternative platforms where
all the different videos that are put
onto YouTube are also put onto the
alternative platforms okay like Rumble
and and bitshoot and those and then also
we have our download server now all of
these um platforms the links to them are
in our descriptions of the YouTube
videos and also on our website clashof
minds.com there you can find all the
alternative links and even more download
material and then there's another
announcement that we will be in Ireland
from the 17th of July till the 20th of
July with an outreach program there if
people would like to have more um
information on that there's also going
to be a email address
popping up on the screen and then also
in the description so they can email the
email address and find out more on that
so Martin the trouble is that uh you
know some of the the
media Moguls have decided that they're
not going to censor anymore mhm but that
doesn't seem to be working through to
the channels that we have on on
YouTube they believe that if you say
something that doesn't fit the popular
narrative then you have to censor it
yeah well I can just mention it was one
of our Walt cross videos but it this
will probably still be happening so
that's why I want to to encourage people
the the viewers and and the more
stringent they
become as we move along in the Stream of
time some of the other issues that they
do not now censor will be sensored so if
people find that we're suddenly black
and no longer there the screen's gone
black then click on the alternative ones
maybe they'll take them down too but uh
we'll keep going as long as they can
then we've still got our download server
going so if all else fails we'll try and
see how we can communicate but please
get used to using the alternative watch
the Drone doesn't fly
it and then there's some interesting
news also with our health center would
you like to tell us yes our health
center Verity Center is up and running
there's also our web page you can have a
look at what is happening there and
we're very happy with that with that
progress and uh the Lord is sending
people that have need to be there and
our school yes is also up and running
and our next intake is at the end of
this month and it's already fully booked
and it's fully booked so very praise the
Lord all systems go so it's a very
hectic year Martin mhm we have campaigns
we have camp meetings we have to travel
overseas on a number of occasions and uh
then come back and then have our
WhatsApp Prof series plus other
campaigns and then also all the other
things like the schools Etc that will be
taking place again so uh the Lord will
have to give us a special vitamin
injection yeah that's true and all
prayers is
appreciated for sure so that's right I
think with that now we can open focus on
on the issue at hand yes so let's look
at this comment SL question on the last
WhatsApp
Prof and it says that the was good
information but it does not highlight
what people should do to overcome in the
time of
trial that makes the session a bit
one-sided and a scary story with little
or no comfort for God's people perhaps
we can just say we've spoken about these
issues over and
over and one never knows you know who
who's coming in and doesn't have the
background of what went before and we
have to always make sure that that we
don't leave people behind but take them
along on the
journey and seeing that this is also
something that we consider as an
Evangelistic tool yeah it's necessary
that we talk about these things so
people can be informed these are their
questions
that's I also ask and have asked in the
past the question if Christ has
fulfilled the law why do people have
have to keep the Sabbath are we saved by
works or by faith in the keeping of the
Sabbath how does this time with Romans
14: 5 and
6 the instructions to the early
Christians in Acts 1528 and 29 does not
mentions the observance of the Sabbath
to the Gentile Believers as one of the
critical issues I hope someone can give
a fair explanation about this because
these are important issues that should
not be glossed over or avoided or
regarded as enemy of the church activity
people do have tough and important
questions so we thought you know Martin
maybe we should talk about these things
again just to put it back into
perspective especially after the last
video because that was maybe a little
bit one-sided because of all the
previous ones that led up to it that
that put the um background there yeah so
if you jump into the Fry at this
particular point you could find yourself
swimming yeah that's true all right so
how do we deal with this kind of issue
now the topic is so vast you you cannot
possibly deal with it in a session no so
we'll just briefly go over we'll try and
answer uh all the components that we
have over
there all right so in the time that we
are living in now where prophecy is
fulfilling before our eyes what is the
first priority in the times that we are
living
in it has to do with your heart okay so
I think the first priority is definitely
a personal
preparation you cannot commit to others
what you haven't internalized yourself
that's it
right it's like a teacher who tries to
teach mathematics if he's never studied
mathematics it's going to be a
disaster and if you don't believe in
what you want to teach yes then it's
going to be all farted so correct so you
need a personal
preparation so I thought about the 10
virgins and the 10 virgins are called
virgins because they know and confess
the truth right they're
undefiled they know the truth and they
speak about the truth
the lamps that they carry represent
God's word all right and this word is
then a light unto their paths Thy word
is a lamp unto my path and the light
unto my feet that's
biblical the oil is a symbol of the Holy
Ghost which all had as their guide and
teacher all 10
virgins some assimilated the light they
had received into their characters and
some had neglected this
work and then there's a tearing time and
tearing times can lead to
complacency that's so true isn't that
true
mhm and the spirit Works in accordance
with one's desire for
it you must want the spirit for sure you
can't just study it like you you study a
script of something this is not a scpt
script it's not a story it's a
reality so you might know what the
spirit says but does it convict you and
change you so the spirit Works in
accordance with one's desire for it
yeah and your cry must be like in Psalms
51:10 create in me a clean heart oh God
and renew a right Spirit Within Me renew
a right Spirit Within Me and the psalm
of Assa says truly God is good to Israel
even to such as are of a clean heart so
the question is if God is good to those
that have a clean heart how did they get
a clean heart only by him obviously
create in me a clean heart you can't do
it create he he must all right you can't
tell a dirty room clean
yourself it just won't happen it'll get
worse right for sure so somebody has to
clean it you have to go take a broom and
you have to start
sweeping and the only one who knows what
is good and what is bad is God yeah
because the heart is the heart is
deceitful above all things and
desperately wicked so
cover follow your heart is not a very
good principle Hollywood um motto is not
very good no no all right now do people
really want this Clean Heart Mart no
Ezekiel 33 tells us the condition of
virgins this is God's
people and they come unto thee as a
people cometh and they sit before thee
as my people and they hear thy
words but they will not do
them for with their mouth they show much
love but their heart goeth after their
covetousness this doesn't apply to me
this applies to that time or this time
or that other this was inspired but this
was not inspired I will decide what was
this inspired according to my
covetousness right that's true so
whenever you read something that you
have to
change you just bring it upon yourself
that you can decide when and where so M
when you talk about creating me a clean
heart that's coming back into harmony
with God
and the Clean Heart must be associated
with the righteousness of Christ
right so that's the first
preparation and just for interest sake I
thought we'd throw this in as well that
there's no one righteous no not
one because you know as soon as somebody
has achieved something he thinks he's
the bee's
knes so if you were a y struck and you
win a lotto and you become a millionaire
that automatically makes you a boss over
everyone right that's how people act
that's a very irrit irritating tray of
some of these
individuals so we must always consider
that there's no un righteous no not one
does that include me then yeah how dare
you sorry to say but
yes it doesn't include you yes
okay so the claim to be without
sin is in itself evidence that one who
makes this claim is far from holy yeah
that's already the first sign okay so
this is a very misunderstood Point yeah
to say that you
are
sinless makes you anything but holy
right MH does that mean that you must
continue to sin no not at all so I have
a sinful nature but that doesn't mean I
must submit to it that's people don't
understand that point no because you see
it's it's such a th fine
line because you have to strive for it
but the problem is once you achieve some
of it you start getting boastful or
self-righteous and then you need a Bonks
on the bean
mhm it is because people have no true
conception of the infinite Purity and
Holiness of God or of what they must
become who shall be in harmony with his
character because they have no true
conception of the Purity and exalted
loveliness of Jesus and the malignity
and evil of sin that's the
contrast that human beings can regard
themselves as holy so in other words if
you say You Are Holy you have become
holy then you've already lost the then
you've already lost the point but God
may say it he said you are a holy people
a holy priesthood let him say it but you
should never utter it right that's the
thing and as soon as you say it it
becomes boastful that's it it's you and
the other thing is as soon as you say it
or you believe it then you also become
not humble anymore correct know we
always say be perfect as your father in
Heaven is perfect but perfectionism is
from the evil
one the greater the distance between
them and Christ and the more inadequate
their conceptions of the Divine
character and requirements the more
righteous they appear in their own eyes
that's when you get to the phical
condition so Martin the safer one is to
acknowledge that you are a sinner yeah
and that you are totally dependent upon
Christ
not to sin yeah how's that 100% the
sanctification set forth in scripture
Embraces the entire being Spirit soul
and body you can't leave one or the
other one out you cannot say I will be
holy in my in my spirit and then keep on
fornicating
yeah that doesn't work doesn't work Paul
prayed for the Thessalonians that their
whole spirit and soul and body be
preserved blameless unto the coming of
our Lord Jesus Christ quoting 1
Thessalonians
5:23 again he writes to Believers I
beseech you therefore Brethren by the
mercies of God that you present your
bodies a Living Sacrifice holy
acceptable unto God so Mar there's a
work to be done if you want to be in
harmony with God a transformation has to
take place okay now God often gives
these
instructions and humanity is very good
at ignoring them
yeah and giving good ideas why they want
to ignore all right let's take Samson
for
example he had to be a
Nazarite and he had to abstain from from
drink and all of these issues and
uncleanness and all of it how many of
the rules did he break quite a few quite
a few the consequence es were very good
for him right it was Dire all right it
took a terrible toll upon him yeah and
only when he was really
blind did he eventually see
see so M these are all lessons in the
Bible that we have to learn so the first
preparation starts here yeah the events
connected with the close of Probation
and the work of preparation for the time
of trouble are clearly
presented but multitudes have no more
understanding of these important truths
than if they had never been revealed
it's a very sad
statement Satan watches to catch away
every impression that would make them
wise unto
salvation and the time of trouble will
find them
unready as we're near the close of the
world's history the prophecies relating
to the last days especially de demand
our
study the last book of the New Testament
scriptures is full of the truth that we
need to understand the solemn messages
that have been given in their order in
the Revelation are to occupy the first
place in the minds of God's people so
Mar if the first place is to be a
preparation of the heart and the first
place has to be a study of the
scripture how do you marry those two
well when you study the scripture then
the other part will automatically
supposed to come automatically okay but
what if you study the scripture for
information but it doesn't really
contain the oil to be translated into
the into your being then unfortunately
you'll probably be one of the sleeping
versions that wake up and then no have
no well it's too late yeah okay so this
is all nothing thing right in order to
know where you are in the Stream of time
you need need to study if you know where
you are in the Stream of time you must
ask yourself the question am I ready so
it's important if I'm getting the just
of this now that if you study the Bible
and all of this it won't actually be
complete if you don't also study the
signs of the times you have to do them
both you can't be a bench
warmer you have to study and study is
not something that somebody else can do
for you no for sure not so can we say
martin that we cannot possibly keep
Christ if we've never possessed him true
yeah definitely I I kind of like this
statement it is not enough to understand
the issues we must also come into
harmony with the will of God the issues
merely tell us where we are in the
Stream of time they're not going to save
you you can be the most knowledgeable
people on the face of the Earth and
still be lost right that's the thing so
you you can be in it and study it for
sensation just you shock or show
somebody but there's no transformation
of your heart if it doesn't work a
transformation then there's a problem so
we need to know the message mhm we need
to know what we are saying we need to
know why we are saying it and we need to
know what the effect should be on our
own Hearts it's not a hammer to strike
others with it's a double-edged
sword yes it's to strike others but also
to strike yourself so let's have a look
at the essence of the first Angel's
message and the consequential fruitful
life because it's no good giving a
message if it's not a double-edged sword
right so Revelation
146 and I saw another angel fly in the
midst of Heaven having the Everlasting
gospel to preach unto them that dwell on
the earth and to every nation and
Kindred and tongue and people so
obviously we've discussed this many
times the the gospel never changes no
because God also never changes but it
needs to be repeated to people because
they change it
yes and they forget they forget that
they changed
it and so they need to be reminded what
is the essence of the
Gospel saying with a loud voice fear God
mhm and give glory to him for the hour
of his judgment has come and worship him
that made Heaven and Earth and the Sea
and The Fountains of water now there are
certain key words here fear God
mhm judgment MH judgment always has a
standard of judgment it has to be judged
there must be a standard otherwise you
can't have a judgment if you don't know
what's right and what is wrong you
cannot say what is right and what is
wrong true right so judgment implies a
standard of judgment and fear of God
means being in harmony with the standard
of judgment simple as that that's
it so if we want to find out what it
really means then you have to look for
parallel texts and
Ecclesiastes 1213 gives it to us let us
hear the conclusion of the whole matter
fear God there we have it m but what do
I do if I Fear God keep his Commandments
that's it that's that's the whole duty
of man it's Can it can it be any clearer
no it cannot and there's no confusion
about this no what I love about this
it's in
Revelation yes so it takes you back to
the Old Testament and even to Genesis
because that God that you have to fear
is the one who made the Heaven and the
Earth and said it in Genesis already so
it's not it's not rocket sence fear God
and come into harmony with his standard
of judgment if you know want to know
what it is well then what does fear God
is keep his Commandments and now it's
not the fear that you have if you walk
in the dark this is a re reverence yes
that's why you want to keep it it's not
it's not being afraid it's being
reverent to God and being obedient to
some of his requirements right why you
laughing no it's all oh I see all of his
requirements but you know some people
say we confess it but we don't want to
do
it all right and it it's Body Mind and
Spirit everything must be cleaned up
it's a hard one it's a hard one all
right so that's the essence of the
message and this message
comes after the beginning of the time of
the end right okay so maybe because
we're doing it just quickly tell us when
the D of the end according to the
scripture begins at the end of the
1,260 days that is the time of papal
persecution which ended in
1798 then there was a deep study of the
scriptures and out of that deep study of
the scriptures they discovered the
sanctuary message the message of Daniel
the 2,300 day prophecy
and then after that which ended in 1844
if you study all of that this message
goes out hey we have to look at the
gospel again because salvation means
salvation from sin not salvation in sin
what is sin sin is the transgression of
the law what is the standard of judgment
the law is the standard of judgment what
is the fear of of the Lord is doing what
he says simple as that the conclusion of
the whole met so it's it's not rocket
science it's a very straightforward
message hey folks you've made your own
Gospel dump it in the garbage and look
at the real gospel God is a god of can I
say it common sense yes yeah so this is
common sense so it's a very simple
message and the people all say yay we'll
do it
yes but they didn't but they won't no
they won't all right all right so the
question that we had in the beginning is
you know why should we keep the
Sabbath you know the law isn't that all
works works based religion we don't have
the law anymore right so let's just make
sure Matthew 5 think not that I've come
to destroy the law of the prophets I am
not come to destroy but to fulfill this
is what he said if he fulfilled it why
do we have to keep
it well if you follow Christ mustn't you
following these footsteps yes so if he
fulfilled it in other words kept the
essence and lived it as an example then
shouldn't we follow that example or
should we say okay you did it I don't
have to do it so you stopped fornicating
fortunately I can continue fornicating
now because you stopped that doesn't
even make sense no it's it's totally
so that fulfillment is not taken away
destroyed or gotten rid of that is to
show you exactly how you should do it
exactly all right so don't think that
I've come to destroy the law for verily
I say unto you till Heaven and Earth
pass one jot or one tit shall in no wise
pass from the law till all be
fulfilled the law stands
immovable yeah
right whoever therefore shall break one
of the least of these Commandments and
shall teach men so shall be called least
in the Kingdom of Heaven now some people
read that as saying oh well that's okay
I'll still be the
doorkeeper but uh if you read a little
bit further it says you shall no case
enter into the kingdom of abam that
means you will be out pal it was a is it
was a soft statement to say you're not
going to be there statement yes but
whosoever shall do and teach them the
same Shall be Called great in the
Kingdom of Heaven so you have two
classes
here the one class says that you do not
have to keep the Commandments and you
can break one of the least of them you
can break them that's okay and they will
be called least and they shall in no
case enter into the kingdom of heaven
but those that teach that you have to
keep them they shall be called great in
the Kingdom of Heaven simple is that
there are people that also
state in that Matthew 5:18 till all be
fulfilled that on the cross Jesus said
it is finished oh so now you don't have
to be obedient anymore so the devil got
thrown out of heaven for Disobedience so
that we can come back into heaven with
disobedience doesn't make sense doesn't
make sense so the all be
fulfilled is pointing towards when
everything is finished when the price
was paid for sin but sin was not
eradicated mhm we are still living here
and you just have to watch the news to
see that sin is alive and well so only
after the second coming then these
things will start that and it will it it
won't pass away the law no because then
you'll have chaos again God it will be
kept forever and ever and ever it's an
immutable law that's why Proverbs 28:4
says they that forsake the law praise
the
wicked but such as keep the law contend
with them so Martin is there going to be
Strife about the law
oh if you forsake the law then you're on
the side of everybody else that forsakes
the law but if you keep the law you're
at War yeah you're at War the law is the
issue
well the law is the issue so the
question that was asked there so does
this law and the Sabbath still stand I
think is adequately answered here MH but
let's just dive a little deeper and make
sure I found it interesting that the
phrase keep the
Commandments like a like a law keep the
Commandments occurs exactly 10 times in
the King James version of the Bible that
is there are many statements about
keeping the Commandments but it's his
Commandments or must love the
Commandments or this and that and the
other but the phrase keep the
Commandments occurs 10 times that is
very interesting is that interesting so
I thought let's read them excellent all
10 times yeah and see what it
says you shall not add unto the word
which I command you neither shall you
diminish ought from it is that what
Jesus repeated in that previous
statement not one jot or title I have
not come to abolish the law not one jot
will be either taken away or added is
that a repeat
yeah that you may keep the Commandments
of the Lord your God which I command you
oh but that's Old Testament isn't it
modern Deuteronomy 617 ye shall
diligently keep the Commandments of the
Lord your God and his testimony and his
statutes which he has commanded
thee so the Commandments are always a
category and then there are other things
like dietary laws etc etc
711 Thou shalt therefore keep the
Commandments and the statutes and
judgments which I command thee this day
to do
them 86 therefore Thou shalt keep the
Commandments of the Lord thy God to walk
in his way and
to fear Him isn't that interesting so
it's once again where you started off
with to fear God is to keep his
commandment fear fear God and that means
keep his Commandments and that was in
The Book of Revelation that's New
Testament to keep the Commandments of
the Lord and his statutes which I
command you this day since interesting a
lot of them are in Deuteronomy right the
Lord shall establish the holy people
unto himself as he has sworn unto the if
Thou shalt keep the Commandments of the
Lord thy God and walk in his ways you
remember the one we did on the seismic
shift where you mentioned that the lord
always brings their history in front of
them again so to remind them to remind
them to go back to the Commandments the
worst thing that
happened is when the devil convinced
Humanity to take a pair of s
and to sever the Old Testament from the
New Testament the Old Testament is the
gospel in type the New Testament is the
gospel in Verity the one stands upon the
other the one is the Fulfillment of the
other the one is not the negation of the
other then in Psalms 119 verse 115
depart from me ye evildoers for I will
keep the Commandments of God so
obviously there are those that keep them
and those that don't keep them and those
that don't keep them are called what
evildoers yeah and they don't want you
to keep it that's why he said to them
depart from me so therefore you will
contend with them yep and they will be
angry because they want to do their
thing but Martin L jumped to the New
Testament and he said unto them why
callest thou me good there is none good
but one that is God but if thou W enter
into life
keep the
Commandments now this is a very
interesting statement this individual
called him good he said good
Lord and Jesus said why do you call me
good does that imply that Jesus was not
good no no he wanted to to make a point
right then he said there's none good but
one and that is God in actual fact what
he said to him are you recognizing that
I am actually God yeah that's what he
said right he's asking him that and
actually also acknowledges it that I am
yes because we all know that that's a
rhetorical question it's a I am
statement and then out of that mouth
comes if you want to enter into life
keep the
Commandments and then in Revelation
12:17 and the Dragon was wroth with the
woman with the church and went to make
war with the remnant of her seed those
living in the last days which keep the
Commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus Christ so in other
words they have the package deal yeah
and he has the patience of the Saints
and if you want to have patience of the
Saints then keep the Commandments of God
in the faith of
Jesus Martin is is the law gone
unfortunately it's stands a Commandments
and I'm not going to say unfortunately
fortunately it stands because it's also
giving you the character of God so it
stands all right so M does that include
the Sabbath of
course so let's say why would God say
verily my Sabbath Thou shalt keep if he
didn't mean
it that's a question I would like to
hear answered by the people that say we
don't have to keep it okay speak thou
unto the children of Israel saying
verily my Sabbath you shall keep why it
is a sign between me and you throughout
your Generations that you may know that
I am the Lord that does sanctify you
create in me a clean heart isn't that
what we said yeah all right so if you
want to have a clean heart that means
the Lord Sanctified you what is the sign
that you acknowledge that he Sanctified
you you keep his Commandments and you
keep the Sabbath isn't that what the
verse
say that's what it says 100% this it's
Common Sense again okay all right but
it's sabbaths m so was the
Sabbath ceremonial
no no because it was written in the Ten
Commandments and the other sabbaths were
written in the book of of the law that
Moses wrote with his hand and the
Sabbath was instituted before sin the
ceremonial laws was only BR in after
correct the Sabbath was there and the
law was there because in six days the
Lord created them and the seventh day he
spent time with
them so the Sabbath and the the marriage
vow was inaugurated in Eden and blessed
both of
them so the Sabbath was never
ceremonial the ceremonial sabbaths
pointed to the ministry of Christ which
was fulfilled in him so the question is
did Jesus keep it and did he restore it
to its rightful position that is where
he said I came to fulfill the law to put
it into its rightful position again and
interesting thing is the Jews kept the
right day yeah but they trampled upon
the its precept that's it they made it
so restrictive that it was a burden
rather than a pleasure right and you
must call the Sabbath a delight the
Lord's Day honorable according to
Isaiah so when that didn't work the
devil tried a new tactic and he shift at
the day yeah he said it's the day of the
Resurrection but there is a memorial for
the resurrection that's called baptism
that's
it die with Christ rise with him yes all
right so question did he keep it yes yes
for sure did he restore it to its
rightful position yes yes he stripped it
of the
nonsense that was surrounding it that's
why he did all very many of his healings
on the Sabbath day did the disciples
keep it yes did the early church keep it
yes was it an issue during the
Reformation yeah was it an issue at the
Council of Trent definitely did some of
the reformers keep it yes all right
let's have a look at that but what about
the people that say yes the disciples
kept it and Jesus kept it because he was
a
Jew because he was a Jew yes he kept it
because he was a Jew but the New
Testament calls all Christians Jews as
well thank you all right so let's have a
look at the Sabbath in
time it's absolutely clear that the
early church kept the
Sabbath yeah the Sunday was
introduced by the mixture of paganism
and Christianity
Constantine but uh the fact that there
were
laws which restricted Sabbath keeping
meant that people kept the
Sabbath right yes
obviously all right the venian did they
keep the Sabbath
yeah yes definitely the alians they kept
the Sabbath the Celtic Church kep the
Sabbath the Sabbath and the
reformers this is a very interesting
point we'll talk about it in the moment
a little bit then the seventh day
Baptists they decided that they have to
keep the Sabbath and the seventh day
Adventists yeah this is the only
worldwide Movement by the way the
Seventh Day Adventist that keeps the
Sabbath now during the
Reformation Kat or Andreas bordenstein
was his name and he was from Kad so they
late later called him Kad he was the
dean of the vitberg university in other
words he was Martin Luther's boss yeah
all
right and he and Martin Luther were very
prominent in the reformation and he said
hey shouldn't we keep the
Sabbath but they brushed it aside H
later oswal glate came along this man
over here and said the Bible tells us we
must keep the
Sabbath so he being an anabaptist they
decided
to drown
him because he was contending with the
Brethren on the issue of the Sabbath all
right then finally the issue of the
Sabbath was made very prominent at the
Council of
TR because the argument was do we align
ourselves with tradition or do we align
ourselves with scripture MH and the
Protestant view was solar script the
Bible and the Bible alone and the
Catholic position was the Bible in the
context of
tradition and the argument was finally
settled when the Council of
Trent discussed this for many many
months and the Protestants were
present and the Archbishop of Rego
walked into that Council and said you
Protestants you are saying solar scripa
but you don't keep solar scripa because
you follow the tradition of the Catholic
Church by keeping Sunday yeah therefore
you are not a religious movement even
you are just a
rebellion there was an opport
opportunity for them to say you know
you're right we should keep the Sabbath
but they didn't that was the beginning
of the Fall yeah of protestantism and
that was then from there on making them
part of Babylon again eventually they
grew and became part of Babylon again
because they refused to give up a
tradition in vain you worship me
teaching the Traditions as Commandments
yeah so when did the Catholic
Church implement the
Sunday when did it start to be become a
tradition for them because this was in
the what in the 1600s when the Council
of Trent that's correct but when
Constantine the emperor introduced
Sunday as the day of the Lord when they
mingled this was in the 4th century when
he mingled the Pagan Sunday with
Christianity he he made laws about
Sunday but the Council of
laia which happened a few years
later they the Catholic they the
Catholic Church made an anti- Sabbath
law uhuh so this was in the 4th Century
where they introduced Sunday into the
church to to join up paganism and
Christianity so the Council of Trent
determined that the Protestants were
just a
rebellion because they didn't stick to
their solar script by keeping the Sunday
so the issue was very prominent and
that's why later members of or later
movements out of the Reformation like
the seventh day Baptist for example
decided that they had to keep the
Sabbath and that split that
church and out of that movement came the
information that the Sabbath was still
binding and a Bible study proved it and
therefore the seventh day Adventists
when they were formed kept the Sabbath
yeah so the question is did Jesus
replace
it is there one verse where he replaces
it
no did the Baptists Revisited the answer
is
yes after 1844 when light Shone upon the
law was it again made prominent and if
so
why
well the Bible tells us that Jesus went
into the most holy if you read the book
of Revelation MH in the first portion of
the Book of Revelation he walks amongst
the candlesticks that's in the Holy yeah
but later on he saw the Ark of the
Covenant and so these moved into the
most holy and light Shone upon the law
now when light shines upon the law mhm
doesn't it also shine upon the Sabbath
for sure all 10 inside of the Ark all
right and neid is the Seal of God as the
Bible says he sign of
authority then doesn't it shine a little
bit brighter than the others it totally
shows you what God or What entity like
you mentioned you giving authority to
without the Sabbath there is no specific
deity that you are worshiping
yeah so the question is on this issue is
the planet in Rebellion
yes right does rebellion question
authority oh for sure always right
always and if so is the Sabbath then not
the perfect sign of obedience yeah so
what about in our question we had what
about Romans 145 and 6 right this is how
you should study the Bible yes when you
have these logical questions set out
then you go and read the difficult
verses all right so let's read Romans
145 and 6 one man esteemeth one day
above another another esteemeth every
day alike let every man be fully
persuaded in his own
mind he that regardeth the day regardeth
it unto the Lord and He that regardeth
not the day to the Lord he does not
regard it he that eateth eateth to the
Lord for giveth God thanks and he that
eateth not to the Lord he eateth not and
giveth God
thanks very confusing verse right yes
all right let's unpack it number one
question that I have regarding this
where in the Sabbath commandment in the
Ten Commandments does it talk about
eating and drinking no
way no way no so what's eating and
drinking doing here Martin you have to
look at a little bit further there are
there laws or anything talking about
this all right so where do we find
eating and drinking in the ceremonial
law cuz there are all kinds of
sacrifices and offerings and drink
offerings and and food offerings etc etc
so eating and drinking and regarding
certain days as
important uh has nothing to do with the
Sabbath commandment so what are we
dealing with you well the Jews had
brought the gospel to the Gentiles the
Gentiles were pagans and they had
certain feast days Festival days many of
them holy days holy days
yes the Bible knows of only one holy day
and that's the
doesn't know of any other holy days but
the pagans had many holy days they were
the Feast of EA the Feast of Easter EA
and there were the feasts of the solers
and the this and the that and the other
and these were all holy
days now Martin these pagans now come
into the church and they're wondering if
these holy days are still important yes
or no and Jews that had now become
Christians and had to align themselves
with the thought that the ceremonial
days were nailed to the cross had to say
to themselves well do I still have to
keep this day or do I not have to keep
this day so there was a massive you know
confrontation yeah about what is a holy
day and what is not a holy day
and some people believe you know I'm
going to keep this
day yeah because it's a holy day let's
say the Passover for example or I'm
going to keep this or that other day
well if you are still convinced and you
are doing this because you think the
lord requires it then so be it but if
you think not then that's also fine does
he say that that's exactly what he's
saying that's what he says so he's not
talking about the Sabbath no he's
talking about holy days now
today do we have people even within the
church today that believe that Christmas
should be kept as a holy day yes A
Solstice day must be kept as a holy day
was Jesus born on the 25th of December
or was it the birth day of zus yes and
EA mhm all right so some people believe
that they must keep it and they're very
adamant about it well if you're very
adamant about it and you think that
you're serving the lord then then go for
it but really if I think it's not a holy
day and I think it's a pagan day then
leave me alone that's it that's is
that's what it says there don't make it
a Salvation issue don't make it a
Salvation is got nothing to do with it
so you know to fight the battle every
Christmas and every Easter as to whether
you want to fight this battle or not is
is futile because it'll never go away
true there's no and so the Sabbath ah
there there we don't there it's clear
it's very clear verily my Sabbath you
shall keep unfortunately that's
salvational I think so because it
determines whose authority you align
yourself to well just maybe to clarify
before we get thrown with stones when
you understand the issue of the Sabbath
then it become salvational sure because
if you reject the Sabbath and accept the
spous
Sabbath fully knowing what the scripture
says and why it says it then becomes
salvation and when their laws start
coming in and it becomes the mark of the
beast then also correct you'll have tode
so the last great conflict between truth
and error is but the final struggle of
the longstanding controversy concerning
the law of
God that's really what it's all about
yeah fear God and keep his Commandments
this is the whole duty of man upon this
battle we are now entering a battle
between the laws of men and the precepts
of Jehovah between the religion of the
Bible and the religion of fable and
tradition that's the war it's not a new
war it's an old war was just fought on
different levels so we should study the
great way marks that point out the times
in which we are living we should now
pray most earnestly that we may be
prepared for the struggles of the great
day of God's
preparation those who place themselves
under God's control to be led and guided
by him will catch the steady tread of
the events or dained by him to take
place inspired with the spirit of him
who gave his life for the life of of the
world they will no longer stand still
and in
impotency pointing to what they cannot
do putting on the armor of Heaven they
will go forth to the Warfare willing to
do and Dare for God knowing that his
omnipotence will supply their need so
this is our duty in the time that we are
living now understand the issue then
preach the issue yeah though the heavens
fall and then that's our duty also live
it all right internalize it now the
question was well what hope is there for
us do what is right and leave the
consequences to God
yeah so during the Christian
dispensation the great enemy of man's
happiness has made the Sabbath of the
fourth Commandment an object of special
attack but if you keep the Sabbath you
will come into conflict with everybody
that does not keep the Sabbath that's
true it's amazing um if some arguments
are that um I can keep any day but that
same person that tells you that has
still got a problem with you keeping it
on the Sabbath on the Saturday correct
and if you spend all your time with them
six days a week but you refuse to do it
on the Sabbath you are an enemy yeah how
many marriages are destroyed by such
arguments and Satan says I will work at
Cross purposes with God God I will
Empower my followers to set aside God's
Memorial the seventh day Sabbath thus I
will show the world that the day
Sanctified and blessed by God has been
changed by what Authority you know even
all the Protestant
denominations admit there is no
Authority in the Bible for the change
yeah thus I will show the world that the
day Sanctified and bless has been
changed that day shall not live in the
minds of the people I will obliterate
the memory of
it I will place in its stead a day that
does not bear the credentials of God a
day that cannot be a sign between God
and his people and I will leave those
who accept this day to place upon it the
sanctity that God placed on the seventh
day that is such a direct attack on the
authority of God through my vice
Regent that's the Pope I will exalt
myself the first day will be ex told and
the Protestant world will receive the SP
of Sabbath as genuine through the
non-observance of the Sabbath that God
instituted I will bring his law into
contempt the words assigned between me
and you throughout your Generations I
will make to serve on the side of my
Sabbath that's his argument that's how
he argues yeah and he's very successful
very successful and uh he twisted it so
like exactly like it stated there that
Holiness that was supposed to be for the
true Sabbath of God is now given to the
Sabbath of him yes yes he gives it the
same sanctity now Martin if we are
living in the last days we must really
understand the issues
right so if this is one of the reasons
that led to the fall of Babylon and it
really started early on and God is very
longsuffering there in the council of
Trent they had every opportunity to set
it right and they didn't then comes the
second Angel's message the first one
says fear God mhm and that also points
to the
Commandments and the second one
announces the fall of
Babylon now we must remember that
Babylon sits as a queen the Bible says
so she does not see her condition and
cannot announce her own
fall CU she doesn't believe that she's
Fallen exactly leave is still standing
yeah she claims that she will not suffer
loss of children so someone else must
call her children out of her ranks right
that's it so she's not going to call it
herself no so somebody else must do it
is that somebody else going to be
popular no no
no so let's just recap why did Babylon
fall yeah well the Bible gives us three
reasons first one is
Doctrine worship the Beast if you
worship
ship the Beast you are following its
doctrines rather than God's doctrines so
that includes all our false doctrines
from the immortality to Purgatory to
baptism to you name it infant
baptism so that's the first point
following the false Doctrine in direct
contradiction to God's word makes her
fall that's it does the Sabbath become
part of that oh for sure does the
immortality of the Soul become part of
that or the negation of the atonement
through Purgatory yeah yeah that the
blood was so if you call a church that
says you pay for your own sins in
purgatory if you have Harmony and
cohesion with her aren't you aligning
yourself with eror deliberately
definitely um if you take a Protestant
Church most well all
how many of these doctrines the false
doctrines have they accepted of the
Beast system a lot of them a lot of them
not all of them not all of them one is
too many that's it unfortunately even
one is too many too many yeah all right
that's the first point they accept their
doctrines that makes them fall the
second one is they use the
state to force people to follow their
doctrines that's coercion Marin and
that's the worship of the image church
and state together yeah and the third
point is Merchants aligning themselves
in forcing and receiving the mark So
once these three are all in place then
we are at the end that's it right so
number one Doctrine the churches have
long already accepted the doctrine the
church and state power was broken in
1798 the Bible says they will be an
image to the Beast church and state will
be
reinstated so that's one of the things
that must happen so just
explain is it true that the image will
not be the Beast itself but it will do
everything that the beat requires of it
correct so it is its lacky yeah
so the Bible tells us in Revelation chap
13 that the United States will do on
behalf of the papacy the first Beast
that which the papacy did during the
Middle Ages in other words enforce its
doctrines that's it so once church and
state come together we know that we are
in serious trouble and once the
merchants jump onto the bandwagon and
help to enforce the mark of the beast by
not buying or selling or not allowing
buying and selling because that's where
the rubber meets the road right then
Martin you have the full
catastrophe now if we take our last
discussion church and
state that is are they coming together
oh definitely all right so they come
together the merchants M oh they already
on on board trade Wars yeah now Martin
trade Wars can you have a trade War
without Merchants no can you forbid the
selling of cars if there's no
manufacturer of cars no so the merchant
must be on board yeah and the merchant
must be an agent in the enforcing
thereof oh for sure so if you go to the
shop MH are you dealing with the
government or are you dealing with a
merchant with a merchant and if the
merchant says to you no yeah you will
not buy is he on board yes all right so
you need them all three you need all
three you need the false
Doctrine you need the state to make the
laws then you have the image of the
Beast and then you have the merchant to
play his part yeah uh oligarchs are they
on board for sure definitely are they
are they forcing countries yes are they
taking away funding of countries yeah
yeah taking away funding putting tariffs
on now tariffs on Goods now who supplies
those goods and disseminates the goods
the merchants you have to have them all
three we and we very much there already
we must be there we must be there okay
so let's look at the Bible you know we
mustn't just speak out of no our thumbs
thumb noology like you always say yeah
all right so look at the first reason
the doctrines all the nations have drunk
of the wine that's the doctrine of the
WTH of her fornication of her apostasy
and the kings of the Earth have
committed fornication with her and the
merchants of the Earth are waxed Rich
through the abundance of her delicacy
there you have the full
catastrophe Revelation 148 and they
followed another Angel saying Babylon is
Fallen is Fallen that great City why
because she made all the nations drink
of the wine of the WTH of a fornication
they swallowed the false doctrines yeah
they believe in the false Sabbath they
believe in all of this ecumenical
nonsense unity in
diversity and negating Christ yes
negating Jesus in the process so instead
of teaching biblical Doctrine the
churches teach the Commandments of men
and disseminate the false doctrines of
Babylon like the state of the Dead
dominionism temporal Millennium
futurism spiritualism you name it across
the board right the second
reason let's start with the time of
Christ at the first coming of Christ the
kings of the world were array against
him yeah and so shall it be at the
second
coming for sure history repeats itself
there's nothing new Under the Sun Our
Savior never asked that the worldly
Powers should defend his truth or his
Doctrine the gates of hell would not
Prevail against them so who was going to
defend them God was going to defend them
he is the one that's
fighting there was no coercion required
or Force the Sheep would hear his voice
and they would follow they would not be
herded or corraled
into pens yeah so by identifying with
the state the churches have lost the
power of the kingdom of God they no
longer rely on the kingdom of God they
now rely on the state yeah so they're
saying what to God sorry we don't need
you we don't need you well that's a very
scary um statement that you made there
because we must be careful that we don't
capitulate because we want to identify
with the state rather than now what if
you if the state makes laws and you want
to be in a nice place there and you
enforce those laws as well then you
become part of a coercive power which is
a very dangerous thing to do because God
never used that power in fact he forbade
it yes all right so acts 4:26 tells us
that the kings of the earth stood up and
the rulers were gathered together
against the Lord and against his
Christ it's going to happen again yeah
for sure Psalms 2:2 go to the Old
Testament the kings of the earth set
themselves and the rulers take counsel
together against the Lord and against
his anointed same thing same thing
nothing's
changed so at the second coming the
rulers will do the same under demonic
guidance how do we know Revelation 16:14
for there are spirits of
devils working miracles which go forth
unto the kings of the earth and the
whole world to gather them to the battle
of the great day of God Almighty they're
going to fight against God
yeah
right and Revelation 17 two tells us
with whom the kings of the Earth had
committed fornication and the
inhabitants of the Earth had been made
drunk with wine of the fornication so
it's the same thing and the woman th
sawest was the great city which Reigns
over the kings of the earth so is a
church in control yes what behind the
scenes behind the scenes she's there
yeah right with her Knights of Mal and
her Jesuit people all there and her
Cardinal dolans and you name it with a
state all right Revelation
18:3 why for all nations have drunk of
the wine of the wrath of a fornication
so they're all drunk with false
Doctrine the kings of the Earth have
commun have done this fornication and
the
merchants all of them are together in
corrupt Harmony that's why you see them
time and a time again go to the Vatican
right so let's look at the merchants the
merchants play their part in the fall of
Babylon they are a tool of
coercion he who controls the money
thinks he controls the
Mind governments and Merchants must be
in corrupt Harmony if they are to compel
the
conscience is that right that's right
what what we spoke about last with what
is happening in this new
Administration it's all there it's all
there I I I just have that a thought now
when you we read
this there's
two people the top of the country the
leader and then he's the merchin yeah
and they are very much in cahoots at
this stage
absolutely so Ezekiel 27 verse 33
already said when thy words went forth
out of the Seas thou fillest many people
thou did enrich the kings of the Earth
with a multitude of thy riches and of
thy
merchandise so what's happening in Gaza
is very interesting it's going to be the
new Riva maybe who knows you know all
nations have drunk of the wine of the
WTH of a
fornication and the merchants are waxed
Rich through the abundance of her
delicacy those three together make up
the final plot the Unholy Alliance the
Unholy Alliance so Martin what is our
duty in the last time make right with
God and uh obey his instructions get out
of the Cities yeah don't live in the
influence of the Cities secure for
yourselves land where you can grow your
own vegetables because the time of
buying and selling is going to be a
reality you might want to have a carrot
in your garden you might want to have a
pumpkin in your garden and you might
want to have a sweet potato and a potato
in your garden so that you've got
something to eat when you can't buy and
sell yeah so staple food all right so
we're going to go to a little and a
great time of
[Music]
trouble psalms 27 verse 5 for in the
time of trouble he shall hide me in his
Pavilion in the secret of his Tabernacle
shall he hide me he shall set me upon a
rock that's Jesus yeah so might do I
have to panic about the time of the end
no who has to panic about the time of
the end the ones against the enemy
right 3739 but the salvation of the
righteous is of the Lord he is their
strength in the time of trouble the Lord
is good a stronghold in the day of
trouble and he knoweth them that trust
him so number one is we've said this
before the ones who are in trouble in
the time of trouble is not God's people
it's the other side it appears to be
God's people yes because the laws are
against
and you are distressed yes and the
merchants are against you and the state
is against you and the church is against
you and everybody reviles you but really
they are in
trouble so probation has not yet closed
when you are in the little time of
trouble no the plagues are not falling
but you will have turmoil in the cities
you will have natural disasters
multiplying there will be fires there
will be tornadoes there will be floods
earthquakes spiritualism will be
manifesting itself with signs and
wonders and they will be contradicting
the word of
God look at Roberts and Marlo's last one
on the immortality of the soul and see
whether that is a reality or
not then there will be economic pressure
brought to bear on those that refuse to
the mark of the beast 25% tariff no 50
yeah if you keep up 100 that's it how
much can you use of your bank account 25
no 50 no nothing nothing we take it away
okay oh well that's it's a reality that
will probably be there get out of the
Cities as God opens the way grow your
own
vegetables spread the message which will
swell into a loud cry before probation
closes that's your job that's your job
now well and do hard searching and let's
put it straight that's now that's now
we're there we're there start doing this
now how much more do you want these
things come together it's never been
like that no if you don't do it now then
by the time it really gets tough you're
going to you're going to have trouble
yeah it is the glory of the Lord to be
merciful full of forbearance kindness
goodness and truth but the Justice shown
in punishing The Sinner is as verily the
glory of the Lord as is the
manifestation of his Mercy retri ution
is
coming and what a wonderful position to
be in to be able to be on the side
that's not going to be part of the
retribution and the yeah that's
important who the whose retribution is
it it's God's going to do it it's not
people there's not going to be a Revival
of people doing this no there will be a
Revival of primitive godliness yes but
he will do the fighting so the time of
trouble such as never was is soon to
open upon us and we shall need an
experience which we do not now possess
and which many are too indolent to
obtain it is often the case that trouble
is greater in anticipation than in
reality but this is not true of the
crisis before us the most Vivid
presentation cannot reach the magnitude
of the ordeal and that time of trial
Every Soul must stand individually
before God though knowah Daniel and job
were in the land as I live says the Lord
God they shall deliver neither son nor
daughter they shall but deliver their
own Souls by their
righteousness and it's he that declares
them righteous not they that's
it so seek ye the Lord all ye Meek of
the earth which have wrought his
judgments seek righteousness seek
meekness it may be he shall be hid in
the day of the Lord's anger heart prep
ation number one transgression has
almost reached its limit confusion fills
the world and a great terror is soon to
come upon human beings the end is very
near God's people should be preparing
for what is to break upon the world as
an overwhelming
surprise Martin are we there we've had a
few surprises in the recent
future it's very well
put and the re past yes and even that is
not comparable to what's coming no so
what must we do we must actually
increase our efforts Martin yeah we are
nearing the great and final Conflict
every Advanced move made now must be
made with increasing effort for Satan is
working with all power to increase the
difficulties in our way he works with
all deceivableness of unrighteousness to
secure the souls of men I'm to say to
ministers of the gospel and to our
missionary Physicians go forward the
work to be done calls for self-
sacrifice at every step go forward so
ulence is not what we need now no now is
the time to work to work all right so
you do the hard preparation and that
compels you to go
forward there's no time to lose the end
is near the passage from place to place
to spread the truth will soon be hedged
with dangers on the right hand and on
the left you think the devil's going to
allow you to preach the truth well that
I think that passage from place to place
will soon be I think it's it's already
here yes it's not that soon be it we've
already got this everything will be
placed to obstruct the way of the Lord's
Messengers so that they will not be able
to do that which it is possible for them
to do now that's why we said if if the
screen goes blank please please look at
the the alternative ones if they go
blank look at the web page download get
the message out exactly because of all
of this goes down then every single
person not that that it's not their job
already should then take it further yes
and not wait till it goes down just we
say what happened now no so we must look
our work fairly in the face and Advance
as fast as possible in aggressive
Warfare call a spade is paade and be on
the defense not on the defense and I
understand in that question the man said
you no now you're telling us all these
things that are happening but what about
us trust in the Lord that's it from the
light given me of God I know that the
powers of Darkness are working with
intense energy from beneath and with
stealthy tread Satan is advancing to
take those who are now asleep as a wolf
taking his prey we have warnings now
which we may give a work now which we
may do but soon it will be more
difficult than we can
imagine God help us to keep in the
channel of light to work with our eyes
fastened on Jesus our leader and
patiently perseveringly press on to gain
the victory this is our job now MH and
then we come to the great time of
trouble yes so we're in a preparing time
now we were now in the little time of
trouble so you do what you can you get
out of the Cities you start growing in
if you don't have much ground get
yourself some pots and pl plant
something you can p on potatoes in a
black bag that's it in on a stoop uh
what's a stupid English a veranda a
veranda God has thrust his people into
the Gap to make up the Hedge to raise up
the foundation of many generations in
other words to get rid of The Refuge of
Lies the Heavenly intelligences angels
that excel in strength are waiting
obedient to command to unite with human
agencies you're not going to be on your
own and the Lord will interpose when
matters have come to such a pass that
none but a divine power can counteract
the satanic agencies at work when his
people shall be in the greatest danger
seemingly unable to stand against the
power of Satan God will work in their
behalf man's extremity is God's
opportunity get this into your head yes
this is what we this is what you should
hold on to
correct so angels are now restraining
The Winds of strife that they may not
blow until the world shall be warned of
its coming Doom but a storm is gathering
ready to burst upon the Earth and when
God shall bet his angels loose the winds
there will be such a scene of strife as
no pen can picture I can see the hatred
in the Press oh oh I can see the the
animosity the gall that comes out of
some of these people's mouths is just
unbelievable unlogical statements they
if you if you look at some of these
conversations you your mouth goes open
and ask how can you think like that yeah
huh and this will just get worse and
this will be directed for now it's not
as strictly directed towards us but it
will be oh once that once that spear
faces at your heart they're going to
want to thrust it right through you so
this statement man's extremity is God's
opportunity is one that we should burn
into our
minds probation is closed when the big
time of Trouble Comes yeah and God's
people go through Jacob's
trouble because there's nothing they can
do anymore all they can ponder about is
am I right with God have I confessed my
sins am I ready for
this jacob had that struggle with God
yes but he did not have the struggle
about unconfessed sins he had the
struggle did God forgive my confessed
sins did he forgive them am I forgiven
did I have a true repentance there was
no self-exaltation of I'm perfect now no
and Jacob he didn't command him he held
on to him and clung to him until he
prevailed so the repentance is in this
little time of trouble
yes big time of trouble it's too late
right God's people are sealed yes and
remember that they're
sealed and what does that mean just give
us that it means they are so settled in
the truth that they cannot be
moved it's yeah there's nothing more
that man can do to change his situation
therefore in the big time of trouble you
are totally dependent upon God and you
will be totally ostracized by
Humanity it will be a time of great
strife and Nightmare then you're hanging
on to ropes where you cannot see where
they're anchored to yeah well by Fai
Faith all right so all you can do is
lean upon the promises of
God so my favorite verse and I have it
also on my desk so that I don't forget
it is Proverbs 35 and 6
trust in the Lord with all thine heart
and lean not on thine own understanding
in all thy ways acknowledge Him and He
Shall direct thy paths so if you want to
prepare for the time of big trouble
you're wasting your time that
preparation must have been done before
yeah if you're going to get there and
you want to prepare you will find you
don't have oil unfortunately you have
now is the time what is that verse today
when you hear his voice do not Harden
your hearts so Martin let's end with
what happens here in the end that voice
shakes the heavens and the Earth that's
the coming of Christ there's a mighty
earthquake such as was not since the men
were on the earth so mighty an
earthquake and so great quoting
Revelation the firmament appears to open
and shut the glory from the Throne of
God seems flashing through the mountains
shake like a reed in the wind and ragged
rocks are scattered on every side there
is a Roar as of a coming Tempest the sea
is lashed into Fury there is heard the
shriek of a hurricane like the voice of
demons upon a mission of Destruction the
whole earth heaves and swells like the
waves of the sea its surface is breaking
up the very Foundation seems to be
giving way Mountain chains or Sinking
inhabited Islands disappear the sea port
that have become like Sodom for
wickedness or swallowed up in the angry
Waters this these are quotes from
Jeremiah and all of these Bible
prophets and then Babylon the great has
come to remembrance before God to give
unto her the cup of the wine of the
fierceness of his wroth great hailstones
everyone about the weight of a talent
are doing their work of destructions
quoting Revelation the proudest cities
of the Earth are laid down the lordly
Palaces upon which the world's great men
have lavished their wealth in order to
glorify themselves or crumbling to ruin
Before Their Eyes Prison Walls are rent
to under God's people who have been held
in bondage for their faith or set free
so you might end up in jail Martin you
might end up on death
row God will take care of it it's no
longer your
problem so this is our last one when the
work of Investigation shall be ended
when the cases of those who in all ages
have professed to be followers of Christ
have been examined and decided then and
not until then probation will close and
the door of Mercy will be shut thus in
the one short sentence they that were
ready went in with him to the marriage
and the door was shut where carried down
through the savior's final ministration
to the time when the great work for
man's salvation will be completed so
that is a summary of what will happen
now there are many many statements I
have here a little
book it's called the crisis
ahead and it's a compilation by Robert
Olsen and just reading through it you
know you could have hundreds of
statements just on on the crisis
ahead
and there's so much encouragement and so
much warning in all of those we've just
given a little spattering here and there
but this is the issue the issue will be
obedience and the
Commandments the word of God or
tradition that's that's the issue I can
also encourage the the viewers we've got
Mar
that's being AED every single day as a
devotional and maranata is very much
filled with how to get ready how to get
ready so what we are trying to do is get
the message out warn the people what is
the issue how do we prepare as you say
we've got daily devotionals out we have
many speakers that on a regular basis
bring their messages so we are trying to
do what we can but if the people out
there don't become co- laborers together
with this we might find that we have not
reached as many as we should and that
would be a catastrophe so please become
involved become a missionary in your own
right if you don't have the tools use
the ones that are provided not only from
this ministry but from other Ministries
as well well and disseminate them like
the leaves of Autumn we don't have much
time left amen let's pray amen Heavenly
Father what a time to be living in to
see that the image of the Beast is
forming false doctrines have done their
work the kings are being utilized to
enforce them and the merchants are
jumping on board a Time such as never
was is upon us give us wisdom give us
strength give us your spirit in jesus'
name amen amen
[Music]